[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
aujourd'hui en france une femme meurt
tous les deux jours et demi sous les
coups de son conjoint ou de son ex
conjoint depuis le début de l'année 2019
plus de 130 femmes ont été tuées par
leur conjoint ou ex conjoint selon les
chiffres du ministère de la justice
le gouvernement lui s'est engagé à
lutter davantage contre ces violences
conjugales en lançant le premier
grenelle sur le sujet des conclusions
présentées par le premier ministre et la
secrétaire d'état
lundi dernier protéger les victimes
prendre en charge les auteurs éduquer à
l'égalité homme femme le grenelle a
permis d'établir une cinquantaine de
mesures censées notamment enrayer le
fléau des féminicides et rompre cette
spirale de la violence alors les mesures
gouvernementales peuvent elles suffire
comment faire en sorte de prévenir de
tels drames
on en débat en direct ce dimanche avec
nos invités florence toro lyon bonjour
vous avez été victime de violences
conjugales alors que vous viviez il y a
cinq ans dans le jura vous partagez avec
nous aujourd'hui votre notre témoignage
et le parcours qui a suivi ces violences
eric mathais bonjour je vous aime le
procureur de la république de dijon n'a
rien dit bonjour vous êtes présidente de
solidarité femmes 21 vous êtes également
écrivaine merci à tous les trois d'avoir
accepté cette invitation en direct ce
dimanche matin et vous qui nous regarde
et vous pouvez bien sûr et commenter
cette émission avec le hashtag ding pôle
bourgogne toujours en direct et toujours
sur les réseaux sociaux alors florence
toro lyon un mot de votre parcours pour
qu'on comprenne ce qui vous est arrivé
et pourquoi aussi aujourd'hui
vous voulez vous exprimer et partager ce
que vous avez vécu c'est important il y
a cinq ans vous étiez marié et votre
mari a tenté de mettre fin à vos jours
oui alors je vais reprendre un petit peu
parce que voilà ça se passe pas comme ça
il ya des années de violences conjugales
avant il ya des années de violence
psychologique de violence financière de
violences sexuelles
il ya beaucoup de violence avant l'aller
les violences les coûts enfin dans mon
histoire à moi
et effectivement mois d'avril 2014
je fuis cette violence et parce que la
violence est montée d'un cran et je sens
que cette fois ci si je ne pars pas je
vais mourir
voilà j'ai déjà c'est en tête et je
la journée je la raconterai pas à
nouveau où il est extrêmement violent et
du coup je me dis de dégager de la
maison donc je pars cette fois ci je
pars ça durera pas bien longtemps parce
qu'il passera très vite tels actes
derrière après avoir échangé plusieurs
coups de téléphone textos en essayant de
me faire revenir en essayant voilà en
dix ans les phrases telles que ton fils
n'aura plus maman voilà c'est fait c'est
ça se passe comme ça avant santé l'onu
en ce sens je sens l'acte jenson l'acte
venir je vais quand même cinq fonds
gendarmerie c'est à dire que la première
fois c'est une avocate qui m'envoie en
disant 'vous savez vous avez quitté le
domicile conjugal
il faut aller le dire en gendarmerie
alors il faut passer la porte de la
gendarmerie et se dire voilà je vais
aller dire au journal j'ai quitté mon
foyer parce que ses violons et que j'ai
peur de ce qui peut m'arriver
donc je passe enfin cette porte de
gendarmerie hélas le gendarme me regarde
et me dit ouais ouais c'est bon quoi
ouais votre adresse on va la mettre dans
le journal filmé ces dignes de vous ma
nouvelle adresse où je lui cacher vous
allez la mettre dans le journal après
s'enchaînent plusieurs choses c'est à
dire que monsieur viendra volé des clés
et des papiers dans mon véhicule devant
l'ehpad où je travaille je retourne en
gendarmerie je me fais accompagnés par
la directrice de l'ehpad parce que je
suis dit écoute on m'écoute pas on ne
m'entend pas bien avec moi tu me servira
de témoin tout ça donc voilà j'y vais
cinq fois quand même avant et à un
moment donné
le monsieur va à en gendarmerie lui-même
pour dire non non non elle dit n'importe
quoi
les clés c'est moi qui lisent et
soissons c'est ma voiture donc voilà et
là les gendarmes c'est il ya peut-être
un petit problème effectivement madame
est peut-être un peu en danger quand
même et il faut un signalement au
procureur donc du jura et le procureur
demande que j'accélère ma procédure de
divorce c'est la seule protection de ge
et à ce moment là une vire qu'il faut
que j'accélère ma un procédure de
divorce
voilà j'ai pas de réponse à ça je
resserre encore luc la variable jeu ces
briques allez quoi comment comment c'est
possible d'abord une réponse pareille
est bon les jours faisant et il est
passé à l'acte quoi un moment donné vous
y retrouver il m'a retrouvé c'était très
facile on le travaille c'est très
français donc il se présente un matin on
se croise sur la route et je me dis non
va-t-on travail va ton travail c'est
l'endroit il passera pas la porte de ton
travail
il n'osera pas il osera part il a osé et
il a osé et il y est allé et voilà c'est
une attaque à l'armé blanche
donc c'était évidemment c'était vraiment
une mise à mort en disant bon j'ai hurlé
aux premiers coups de couteau j'ai hurlé
parce qu'elle descendait carotide et je
me suis dit faut que jour autrement que
j'ai un cri autre que ce que les
personnes des mets pas tout avoir et que
mes collègues comprennent que j'étais il
y avait quelque chose qui se passait qui
était pas normal
et à ce moment là les arrivées ces
seuils de le calmer ce qui est
absolument impossible et l'huile en
théâtre représentation
voilà je suis aux anges comment ça je me
mets au sol parce que je me dis il
attaque visage il attaquait carotide
j'aime est au sol pour me protéger
un coup de couteau aussi sur le bras et
finalement vos collègues arrivent à le
mée collègues essaye de le tirer et tout
ça et lui la représentation d'y aller
femme voulait votre liberté bien
regarder votre liberté ce que c'est elle
a malheureusement bon comme je suis sous
sous adrénaline ou je ne sais pas quoi
je me redresse contre lui et je lui dis
je les avais fumay malade à ce point là
jamais et move de la lèvre à l'oreille
il est passé par dessus ma collègue qui
est en train de me faire mes premiers
les premiers soins et moi même influence
aurions alors on va dire aussi que cette
personne qui était votre mari à l'époque
des faits est aujourd'hui décédés pour
des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec
cette histoire là et donc il n'a jamais
été condamné
c'est une souffrance j'imagine c'est
épouvantable c'est épouvantable parce
que encore à ce jour bon je suis
reconnue victime
merci aux médias parce que pour moi je
suis séparé vidal voilà je suis n'a qu
enfin j'ai un numéro pour la justice
heures monsieur pro cas où vous direz
peut-être mais pour moi je suis un
numéro
c'est à dire que il décède en juillet je
reçois le non lieu en décembre
voyez laps de temps déjà je suis pas à
former plus fâcheuses ce qui s'est passé
parce que c'est que ddd chose qu'on peut
me rapporter mais je suis pas du tout
informés de ce qui s'est réellement
passé
eric mathais comme procureur de la
république à dijon j'imagine que cette
histoire là elle vous parle je veux dire
vous devez voir des cas de figure comme
cela pas uniquement comme procureur de
la république à dijon évidemment comme
comme citoyen comme être humain c'est
toujours ces témoignages de victimes
madame sont toujours des témoignages
extrêmement émouvant et des témoignages
qui sont importants il est je crois
important il est de notre responsabilité
de d'essayer de revenir sur ces dossiers
pour essayer de faire un un bilan et
essayer de faire en sorte que ce qui a
pu mal se passer éventuellement dans un
dossier ne se ne se reproduise pas là
qu'est ce qui selon vous c'est mal passé
vous n'êtes pas là évidemment pour juger
vos collègues ou ni même la gendarmerie
mais il ya visiblement eu à minima un
accueil de la gendarmerie un peu léger
où je peux dire ça je ne connais
évidemment pas le dossier et c'est
toujours des dossiers qui sont on en
reparlera certainement qu'ils sont des
dossiers compliqués à ce délicat à
traiter
cependant on sait qu le taureau a été
pris par les cornes à la gendarmerie
notamment à la police aussi il ya
maintenant des assistantes sociales qui
forme y compris les gendarmes et les
policiers parce que il ya eu à un moment
donné des personnes qui n'ont pas été
entendus il ya plusieurs choses qui
doivent être central dans ce genre de
dossier c'est l'accueil des victimes pas
d'ailleurs uniquement en gendarmerie
mais tout au long quand vous dites j'ai
l'impression d'être un numéro évidemment
vous n'êtes pas un numéro pour la pour
la justice et c'est vraiment regrettable
que vous ayez ce sentiment là cet
accueil et ses accompagnements il doit
essayer on doit essayer de le faire tout
au long du processus
justement pour que les victimes n'aient
pas le sentiment d'être un numéro parmi
les nombreux les nombreux dossiers c'est
vrai que des dossiers aux communales de
dijon on en reçoit genre soit à peu près
entre 30 et 35 milles parents et des
plaintes pour violences conjugales j'en
reçois environ
550 par parents c'est pas anodin mais
c'est aussi une milieu de tous les
dossiers il est important d'arriver à à
traiter ces dossiers de manière de
manière correcte donc il ya l'accueil et
le ça fait partie du plan du
gouvernement d'ailleurs le renforcement
des intervenants sociaux au sein des
commissariats et des gendarmeries il ya
des questions de formation également
qu'ils sont qui sont importants et
l'accompagnement des victimes par des
associations soient des associations
spécialisées en la matière soient des
associations d'aidé aux victimes est un
point qui est essentiel ce qui est très
difficile
c'est d'arriver à détecter les dossiers
parce qu'il n'y a pas grand chose qui
fait la différence un train entre un
dossier de violences conjugales qui ne
va pas conduire à des faits extrêmement
graves et des dossiers qui vont avoir
qui risque d'avoir des conséquences
dramatiques
wayne rooney voulait dire les disputes
dans le coup j'allais dire un peu
classique et de parfois banales et la
vraie violence conjugale ce qui est
difficile c'est d'arriver à détecter ces
dossiers là et je pense qu'il faut il ya
des lianes il ya matière à projets lancé
en storlien on veut vous répondre puis
je donne la parole à marc ivaldi sur
l'accompagnement avec tout le respect
que je vous dois vraiment je suis
obligée d'intervenir parce que il ya
touche alors on va parler les femmes
décédées mais le chemin de la victime
survivante c'était impressionnant
parce que quand monsieur se sauve avec
le bracelet électronique
après je viens place suquet déposé en
dix ans mais ils m'appellent j'étais
capture d'écran il m'appelle et que je
suis reçue par une dame après sa
détention préventive
je suis reçue par une gendarme
on peut se dire que c'est une femme et
que ça va être bienveillant et non et
elle et le développe elle regarde jamais
il est il est fiché chez vous s'est pas
opposée moi je suis dans une terreur
absolue et elle regarde elle me balance
toutes les affiches toutes les photos
des hommes qui sont qu'ils sont
sous bracelet électronique et quand ça
arrive sur sa photo à lui j'ai tellement
peur je me retrouve sous le bureau de la
dame et elle me dit mais madame il va
falloir être un peu plus costaud que ça
va falloir serrer les poings
parce que votre affaire va falloir être
un peu plus costaud voilà et c'était là
c'est à ce moment là mais tout pendant
mon parcours j'ai vécu des choses comme
ça et là il ya un travail qui a
enclenché qui existe déjà et
effectivement le gouvernement souhaitait
renforcer les intervenants sociaux dans
les commissariats mari marc ivaldi avec
solidarité femmes 21 vous vous
accueillez si j'ose dire à dijon
florence toro lyon au moment où elle est
soignée à dijon après les faits qu'elle
nous a raconté il ya quelques instants
et j'imagine que c'est loin d'être la
seule personne que vous accompagner sur
ce terrain là bas toutes les femmes
victimes de violence ya quand même un
parcours sur sur le sujet de la violence
qui est qui est similaire même si toutes
les histoires sont des violences qui
montent progressivement ce qu'on ne
parlait de violence psychologique de
réagir aussi il ya toute forme de
violence c'est déjà une violence de trop
qu'elle soit psychologique qu'elle soit
économique mais qu'elle soit physique
aussi c'est à dire il ya les femmes qui
sont mortes sous les coups alors on dit
sous les coups mais c'est pas forcément
ccd armes armes à feu coûteaux estime
destination voiture et ses médias aussi
toutes les femmes qui sont victimes de
violence au quotidien on essaie 220
mille femmes victimes de violences donc
effectivement il ya une difficulté de
dire qui va aller à l'homicide ou qui va
pas aller alors si on peut l'entendre
mais toutes les violences sont graves et
mène de toute façon à un
dysfonctionnement grave sociétales
sociales au niveau de la famille on a
des enfants la justice
il ya eu un rapport à du ministère de la
justice lui même on est sensibles nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux faisait
même à mea culpa en quelque sorte quand
elle répondait sur ceux sur sur ce
rapport vous vous diriez
dysfonctionnements de la justice sur les
sur l'échantillon choisi
il ya 80 % des plaintes qui sont classés
c'est madame belloubet qui le dit je
n'invente pas sûr sur un échantillon
bien sûr mais on voit on voit la
difficulté c'est à dire je pense que
d'abord il faut que tous les
forces de police et gendarmerie soient
formés donc passé la première étape
c'est tous ceux qui accueillent
lanthier ceux qui prennent la plainte ça
va être très différent pour une femme de
tomber en gendarmerie dans cette zone ou
en pot distel jours voilà on a des
exemples de femmes qui sont venues en
disant j'ai un problème de violence
cgper et de lui répondre
votre référent est en rtt ou n'est pas
l'art revenez dans cinq jours
cette femme dont je pense elle a été
agressée entre temps heureusement il
serrait il n'y a pas eu de c'était une
agression pas très grave on va dire avec
les pouces xga mais monsieur est venu au
domicile parce qu'il sait voilà
l'histoire d'air donc donc faut vraiment
que avec ma tête le roi revenir aux
formations gouvernementales après
justement pour essayer de modifier ces
choses là je le disais tout à l'heure
qu'il est important d'essayer de te
faire l'analyse de des dossiers passés
pour essayer de progresser c'est
exactement ce que cela décidé là la
garde des sceaux puisqu'elle a confié
c'est ce que vous avez dit à
l'inspection générale de la justice
l'étude de très précisément 88 dossier
de domicile dans un contexte conjugal
commis entre 2014 et 2016 et pour
essayer de voir quels comment on en
était arrivé à cette situation et s'il y
avait eu des dysfonctionnements c'est
vrai que il y a eu une quinzaine de
plaintes dans ces dossiers là dans
quinze dossiers il ya eu des plaintes
qui ont été transmis et sur ces 15
plaintes ya 80% de ces plaintes qui ont
été et qui ont été classés c'est
évidemment pas significative puisque
nous notre taux de réponse quand quand
sur ses 540 plainte que je reçois moi je
donne une suite à dijon on donne une
suite à environ 90 voire 95 % des
dossiers une suite de la plus adaptée
possible donc il y a ceux ci et ce
chiffre bien sûr ça à sa part et parce
qu'il ya aussi des questions de retraite
plainte on y reviendra il ya des
questions de preuves et il ya des
questions parfois de l'attitude de la
victime avec une notion d'emprise qui me
semble forte et donc la démarche qui a
été qui a été fait c'est d'essayer de
tirer les enseignements de ces dossiers
là pour arriver à progresser c'est
vraiment une démarche qui me semblent
positives à vous propose de d'évoquer
ces mesures gouvernementales hors jeu
d'il y a
une cinquantaine on pourra pas tout
toutes les cités dans cette émission
mais le premier ministre et sa
secrétaire d'état ont présenté un
certain nombre d'entre elles
lundi dernier à la suite du grenelle sur
les violences conjugales et notamment
des choses qui concernent la justice la
question du suicide forcé qui pourrait
apparaître dans le code pénal la notion
d'emprise vous en parliez monsieur le
procureur qui devrait faire son entrée
dans le code civil et dans le code pénal
marivin dit est ce que vous vous êtes
satisfaite que finalement le
gouvernement prenne en quelque sorte à
bras le corps ces questions c'est
intéressant parce que on s'y intéresse
mais il faut quand même rappeler que le
grenelle vient aussi après que des
associations depuis des années voilà
demande à ce que les choses évoluent et
évidemment on n'est absolument pas
satisfaite des réponses du grenelle ce
sont des dépenses mans qui sont mis ici
ou là alors ça va dans le bon sens ça va
dans un sens parce que la ligne d'écouté
tendu 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 et
30 noeuds et des choses vont dans le bon
sens mais ça va rattraper le retard dans
lequel on est un requin absolument
vertigineux sur sur ces problèmes là au
dessus au dessus de gendarmerie police
mais même au dessus de la justice faut
une vraie volonté politique c'est à dire
il faut il faut plus de moyens c'est
dommage à niamey c'est parce qu'il faut
aussi plus de fonctionnaires de police
plus de gens formés plus de plus plus
plus plus d'argent aux associations
aussi parce que nous on n'est plus en
capacité de recevoir correctement toutes
les victimes qui franchissent la porte
parce que notamment il ya plus de
victimes qui se révèle à la faveur aussi
de ce grenelle on a vu que le nombre
d'appels par exemple aux 39 19 avait
énormément progressé mais alors c'est
bien de l'ouvrir 24 heures sur 24 mais
il faut des gens formés pour répondre
que ça on est toujours sur ces choses là
il faut voir un petit peu plus haut il
faut voir aussi une vraie volonté
politique qui passe aussi par
l'éducation c'est-à-dire les mesures
elles sont déjà là à l'éducation
sexuelle elle existe c'est pas appliquée
dans tous les collèges il ya plus
d'infirmières et c'est tout ça c'est
aussi en lien avec ces problématiques
qui a le problème de la justice bien sûr
mais tant qu'on se posera pas là
problème
un petit peu plus profondément du
machisme de la société telle qu'elle est
on aura du mal à avancer sur le sujet
faux faux faux ce qui est mis en place
soit appliquée maintenant florence
lyon aussi par rapport à votre parcours
est ce que vous avez l'impression que
les annonces gouvernementales ou qu'est
ce qu'il ya certaines annonces
gouvernementales qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux
alors j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
emmanuel macron 39 19
lors de sa visite j'avais l'impression
d'être entendus j avais beaucoup
d'espoir
j'étais heureuse de ce grenelle parce
que je me dis on en parle ça y est les
choses le fait d'en parler ça fait
bouger les choses c'est super important
vu ça met le doigt sur tous les
dysfonctionnements qui peut y avoir
mais voilà je suis comme marie
maintenant les moyens les besoins on les
connaît mais en face il faut les moyens
et dans une gendarmerie ben même si j'ai
été mal reçue je me dis voilà il faut
travailler pour que les gens soient
formés qui soit pas débordé qui puisse
accueillir une femme comme il doit être
accueilli comme elle doit être
accueillie mais il n'ya pas que les
gendarmeries
il ya le système hospitalier parce que
moi j'ai vécu des choses à l'hôpital que
c était épouvantable on savait pas quoi
faire de moi voulait mettre en hôpital
psychiatrique
voilà il ya tellement de choses à faire
il ya tellement de besoins
mais mettons les moyens en face
suffisant alors il ya des nouveautés à
la notion d'emprise vous en parliez il
est évident que ça semble important d'en
prendre conscience pour le pour le
système judiciaire
la question du suicide forcé parce que
finalement est ce que certaines femmes
qui mettent fin à leurs jours
le fond d'elle-même ou est ce qu'elles y
sont finalement un peu contrainte
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui me
semble très intéressante et très
positive
évidemment dans ce grenelle d'abord on
en parle c'est vrai vous l'avez dit
toutes les deux et puis il ya moins il y
avait plusieurs choses qui m'ont qui
m'ont parlé alors la notion d'emprise
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure on
a souvent dans un certain nombre de
dossiers
une grande difficulté à ce sont des
dossiers qui sont particulièrement
délicat à à évaluer parce qu'on a
parfois des victimes qui ont des
attitudes extrêmement virulente
vis-à-vis de la justice
quand on a par exemple le procureur peut
décider de poursuivre alors même que la
victime a décidé a décidé de retirer sa
plainte et on a assez évoqué fréquemment
des victimes qui viennent jusqu'au
tribunal correctionnel pour protester
contre cette décision du procureur qui
continue à poursuivre et qui demande au
tribunal de ne les attitudes
contradictoires de la victime
ce qu'évidemment souvent elles sont sous
l'emprise et parfois on peut le dire
dans une situation conjugale elles sont
amoureux et voilà notre responsabilité
c'est d'aller au delà de cette attitude
et c'est pas toujours facile en disant
mais justement il ya peut-être une
notion d'emprise une autre des mesures
par exemple c'est d'essayer de
développer et de coordonner les
ordonnances de protection et ça
correspond très exactement madame à
votre situation
quand le procureur vous c'est ce que
vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure vous dis
il faut accélérer notre procédure de
divorce
à l'heure actuelle on peut faire d'une
ordonnance de protection qui est une
mesure particulière et qui peut être
fait très très rapidement dans le cadre
de la procédure de divorce pour protéger
interdire à la personne de rencontrer la
victime
par exemple à dijon nous avons décidé
avec le service de l'application des
peines de coordonner et ça se fait aussi
dans d'autres tribunaux pour qu' il y
ait plus de retenant ce de protection et
les policiers les gendarmes sont
pleinement prenne pleinement partie et
on a plusieurs projets en la matière le
grenelle va nous permettre de développer
cela c'est aussi des moyens puisque le
grenelle c'est 360 millions d'euros dont
10 millions d'euros pour la justice on
va pouvoir développer par exemple les
correspondants sociaux enrouler les
correspondants sociaux dans les
gendarmeries et en un mot quand c'est le
temps passe très vite et avec matin
est-ce que vous avez l'impression par
rapport au rapport du ministère de la
justice que là vous avez de nouveaux
outils pour vous professionnels de la
justice pour mieux travailler
on en a et on a en parallèle du grenelle
il ya on a déjà eu des choses
le grenelle a aussi permis de réfléchir
localement sans attendre les mesures
nationales
par exemple la gendarmerie de bourgogne
a créé une brigade de protection des
familles qui est très intéressante
la police aussi a beaucoup réfléchi on a
accéléré on l'a le traitement d'un
certain nombre de dossiers on a on ça
nous a permis de réfléchir et de d'aller
plus vite sur sur ces dossiers de mieux
les traiter je pense alors parmi les
mesures annoncées la levée du secret
médical dans certains cas précis et de
façon très encadrée je vous propose
d'écouter le premier ministre edouard
philippe
le secret médical c'est un principe
fondateur au coeur de la confiance qui
lie le patient à son médecin et ce
principe qui prévoit des exceptions en
nombre très réduit
nous devons évidemment le préserver nous
devons
respectez nous avons cependant tous en
tête l'exemple de cette femme que cite
le rapport de l'inspection générale de
la justice qui s'est rendu à dix
reprises aux urgences entre 2005 et 2014
donc quatre fois durant la même année et
dont le cas n'est évidemment pas isolé
c'est pourquoi nous devons lorsque le
cela peut sauver des vies
offrir la possibilité aux médecins de
déroger au secret médical
je souhaite que cela concerne des cas
très strictes encadrent et les cas
d'urgence absolue où il existe un risque
sérieux de renouvellement de violence la
ministre de la santé rencontrera le
président du conseil de l'ordre des
médecins pour finaliser le dispositif
c'est une discussion sensible délicate
mais dont nous considérons que si elle
permet d'aboutir un dispositif sur
lequel s'accordent les professionnels
nous aurons là un instrument qui
permettra sans aucun doute d'alerté très
efficacement et de ne pas consciemment
ou inconsciemment fermé les yeux ou
garder pour soi
une alerte qui transmises aurait pu
éviter des drames
alors est ce que les médecins
généralistes notamment ceux qui sont
souvent en première ligne sur ces
questions peuvent lever le secret
médical en cas d'inquiétudes gravats
c'est ce que dit le premier ministre
lawrence toro lyon quel est votre point
de vue moi j'essaie petit par rapport à
ça parce qu'elle la victime a tellement
besoin de confiance
donc si on lève ce moment là est ce
qu'elle voudra parler est ce que les
victimes ou seront parler c'est très
compliqué se livrer aux mêmes bars et
j'ose dire évitez quand elle va appeler
tenir avec un coût mais elle va
peut-être dire aussi que c'est autre
chose parce que parce que c'est
tellement difficile et j'en reprendrais
vos mots sur l'emprise c'est tellement
compliqué quand on est sous emprise et
on a tellement peur aussi il faut dire
la peur qui habite les victimes et les
médecins sont pas forcément défavorable
marivin dit vous
votre association est un peu sceptique
aussi bas c'est la même chose d'abord
enfin moi je comprends pas tellement
cette mesure parce que il me semble
qu'il ya un article de loi qui dit qu'en
cas de choix que c'est un article
222-12-5 qui dit qu' évidemment en
fonction enfin s'il ya vraiment un
danger grave de toute façon le médecin
la possibilité de signaler est
effectivement une femme si elle si elle
pense que qu'on peut lui faire à
l'envers notamment à cause du phénomène
d'emprise qui existe de toute façon dans
tout ce qui dans tous les cas de figure
de violences conjugales l'emprise existe
donc je pense qu'il faut plutôt aussi de
la formation et du temps du temps pour
écouter les victimes voudraient leur
laisser le temps de mûrir du temps pour
faire des enquêtes aussi c'est un petit
peu voilà eric mathais ça pourrait vous
aider cette mesure il ya des médecins
qui sont favorables
sans doute une majorité d'autres moins
question difficile à titre personnel en
tant que procureur de dijon j'y suis
plutôt favorable parce que le c'est un
dispositif qui a fait ses preuves pour
les violences ou et les abus commis
contre les mineurs et contre les
personnes hors d'état de se protéger
mais je suis président de la conférence
nationale des procureurs on en a parlé
avec les collègues
c'est très intéressant parce que les
hommes procureurs étaient plutôt
favorables et les femmes procureur était
plutôt défavorable en dix ans mais nous
ne sommes pas des incapables majeurs
nous ne sommes pas des mineurs les
femmes sont sont responsables et donc
faire cette mesure ça serait d'une
certaine manière il est considéré comme
incapable de se défendre elle même donc
on voit que cet ac les avis sont très
partagés d'ailleurs et donc c'est
intéressant de se poser la question
c'est la question la réponse sera pas
commode à à mettre en oeuvre
au-delà des mesures ce grenelle il aura
on l'a dit tout à l'heure aussi permis
de libérer la parole un peu plus ça il y
avait déjà eu le phénomène nitoo etc
mais un peu plus libéré la parole
la semaine dernière le week-end dernier
dans les rues de dijon va voir quelques
images dans les rues de dijon il y avait
beaucoup de jugement des hommes des
femmes des jeunes femmes qui qui
manifestaient pour dire non aux
violences conjugales
est ce que c'est important et c'est
aussi l'objet de votre témoignage
aujourd'hui si florence or au lieu d'en
parler de continuer à en parler quand on
est survivante
on a comme une charge pour les autres
femmes et c'est vraiment mon témoignage
parce que j'ai un message d'espoir pour
les autres femmes
mais on est debout il ya une vie après
donc allez-y
protégez-vous surtout avant de parler
parce qu'avant je disais parler mais
protégez vous et moi quand je vois cette
jeunesse qui est je me dis mais au moins
elle nous nos mères étaient pas dehors
elle ne parlait pas au moins là ces
jeunes filles on a l'espoir que ça
changera pour elle marie 20-10 ces
images elles sont elles sont marquantes
il ya quelques mois seulement on
n'imaginait pas autant de monde dans les
rues pour dénoncer les cas il ya mis
tout il ya eu donc nous tout qui a
permis de un petit peu de fédérer ce
genre d'actions militantes pour me
pourra parler dans la rue c'est ce qu'on
voit beaucoup aujourd'hui mais je suis
désolé de revenir un petit peu ça le
grenelle a permis bien sûr à parler
beaucoup d'avancé mais c'est que d'abord
c'est pas suffisant et puis c'est les
associations qui sont sur le terrain
depuis longtemps qu'ils font au travail
merci à tous les trois d'avoir accepté
de débattre en direct ce matin merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale avec emmanuel pinsonneault
puis la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
stanislas guérini le délégué général de
la république en marche
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]
l'agroécologie c'est pas de la
cueillette c'est de l'écologie diriger
vers une production agricole durable
les futurs agriculteurs sont tous formés
à l'agroécologie les systèmes
d'aujourd'hui était pas l'avenir la pure
je pense c'est une crainte économique
surtout pour changer tout assisté mais
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain
[Musique]